um all of that
yeah yeah wide grip pull-ups are are
probably the most useful for
building a nice wide thick back and then
some bent over rows will like you know
develop the thickness in your back
yep yep you guys actually have a lot of
details i know that myron put some stuff
together which we'll talk about you know
towards the end that's that's that's
like pre-packaged for you but we'll get
into more details there too later
um okay so we covered the optics let's
talk about money so
how how important is
so um you know just like we talked about
with um with looks like you know we tell
guys all the time you should be maxing
out your looks
money is very important man and that's
kind of one of the foundations of why we
made this course was that we realized
as you deal with more and more
attractive women they're accustomed to a
certain type of
level of man you know what i'm saying
especially here in miami where the
hypergamy is on steroids
so to be able to compete with a lot of
these rappers celebs or whatever it is
you kind of have to uh convey a certain
lifestyle you know what i mean and that
that's done unfortunately through
through money i always say that
women don't necessarily care about money
they care about the freedom that money
provides you know what i'm saying
so if you're able to demonstrate that a
lot of girls will
deal with you just off of the lifestyles
you portray like women thirst trap with
their bodies men their shop with their
lifestyle
and the money allows you to do that now
i know people in the chat are going to
say oh my rooney
myron you're simply no what's going on
with you who cares
and my response to that is this guys you
become high value and earn more money
not to get women rather to not tolerate
the bs that comes from dealing with
women
when you don't have money and it creates
a natural abundance mindset when you're
financially stable where you're not
going to tolerate bs from women and
you're going to walk and move a certain
way when you deal with them
that can't necessarily be faked and um
since and i always say like a man's
confidence a lot of times comes from his
competence and his accomplishments so
you need to be able to get these two
things in check
to get your confidence up so you don't
tolerate the best from women so because
as we know right rich you talking about
all the time chase excellence not women
you know and mess what men must become
money is a very important component
to a man's journey as far as becoming so
uh with finances we definitely wanted to
add this in
uh to like kind of help guys with like
you know basically getting like a basic
understanding of personal finance
credit cards i'm really big into credit
cards and leveraging them to get um
certain perks and making money in 2020
alone i made like thousands of dollars
off of credit cards uh this entire
studio i bought it with credit cards and
then what i did was i just paid it all
off so everything here is paid off but i
use a credit card to buy all this stuff
so i can get thousands of dollars worth
of uh
rewards back and i think that's
something that not enough guys leverage
you know they're paying
cash and credit uh debit cards which i
think is and encourage you know this
because used to
you know get people out of debt but yeah
credit cards if you use them right can
definitely pay back some huge dividends
and then we're also going to be talking
about uh crypto um how
to start a business how to form a
business llc's s-corp so that
uncle sam doesn't destroy you we
actually have our uh um cpa steve who's
gonna be
uh handling the financial portion of the
uh zoom calls because
he's a licensed cpa he down here in
florida and you know he helps guys with
getting their money right and mitigating
their tax liability
so money's critical man you know what i
mean yeah i'll say this i want to add to
that because
um you should really understand where
you live like
your geography is gonna matter when it
comes to the amount of money that you
make
if you live in a very expensive urban
you know coastal type of city toronto
new york
miami la the cost of living is very
expensive if you're making a hundred
thousand dollars a year
you're just average yeah like you're
nothing special
um what you should be doing depending on
where you live and you know you may or
may not want to live there
you know for your entire life i always
tell guys to kind of move around and
experience a little bit i mean
you could be living like a king
somewhere like thailand or the
philippines you know for example or
colombia but
um you talking about north america you
should google the city that you live in
and understand what the top income
earners make in that city and then aim
for the top 10 percent
so i know you know here in toronto
because i had to cover this for a
private cast at one point um for my
community
um i think the average income earner is
like something like 378 000 or 380 000
or something like that
um you want to aim for you know at least
you know getting
getting within the top 10 percent of
income earners if you want to stand out
from the crowds and be spoiled for
choice
and have the options to you know
get access to places like entrepreneurs
organization the royal canadian yacht
club
like all of these high-end events like
when you
money allows you to do things it allows
you
and and and gives you a get out of jail
free pass card for certain places
and exemptions it allows you access to
certain events that you wouldn't
normally get access to
so you're not doing it to be like oh
look at all my money sort of thing but
if you're casually hanging out with your
boys like i have a picture with me
and four other my friends um at the
royal canadian yacht club
in toronto on the island with the
toronto skyline in the background with
the sun coming down with some yachts
kind of like in the bay area over there
and it looks cool as hell
i use that on my online dating game at
the time you know when that picture was
was taken
and i didn't even try to do it i wasn't
even thinking like how do you signal
value you know how do you demonstrate
this it was just that's where i was at
at that place in time
the picture came out great and it worked
out well right because you're
surrounding yourself by excellence
women look at that sort of stuff and
they think to themselves i want to be
there i want to insert myself
here like they think to themselves how
do i insert myself in this part of the
picture
right and it thanks it's really as
simple as that
yeah you know it's funny as well um a
lot of uh coaches right
i think those but you know what you need
game only because they're trying to sell
you something regarding game
right for the most part think about this
right what do women really want
they want to be a part of a good
lifestyle fact that's what they really
want so what happens is right
girls just want to have fun yeah go just
want to have fun my all money is is a
tool
if you have freed up a certain lifestyle
for yourself and you know what if she
wants to be a part of it
better make sure she's cool and you can
bring into it so for example when you
talk about money right
what do you think about uh you think
about buying um cars houses all that
stuff
yeah that's cool and all but guess what
it's a freedom of choice
so when you have money like you said
rich you have options so for example
uh certain events you can go to with a
certain level of money you wouldn't be
invited to
normally for example let's say you're a
guy working a 50k a year job right
yeah you're not gonna get invited to
like a mansion party or like a you i'm
saying
so when you have money of access and for
example the friends that you have
so we've had a couple high network uh
high network individuals here
uh that have a hell of money right
mm-hmm and they say all the time for
example
we can get we can buy the parties based
on the washers that we wear cars we
drive
yeah and when you're there girls see
that and you know what
i want to be part of that like you said
and what happens is they'll do whatever
they can
to get your attention and it's funny
when you have money you can attract them
to you
no obviously you have to filter for gold
diggers of course facts but for the most
part
just having that buffer and being rp
aware and you have the money
you're going to win you're unstoppable
you're unstoppable you become an
unstoppable force
in in the marketplace because because
now you know you're worth exactly and
you won't settle for anything that's
going to
um be less than you which i always say
like you know um
red pill like having game is like having
dynamite kind of you know what i mean
and like
uh if you move throughout the sexual
marketplace without having uh like
rp awareness it's like playing with
dynamite and uh being rp aware also
tells you when to toss that dynamite so
it doesn't blow your arm off
so having that money will allow you to
you know navigate the marketplace
correctly and
you know filter out the girls that just
want to use you for your money
and rich that is the ultimate abundance
mindset when you have the
the money and lifestyle and in the game
you have you're spoiled for choice you
become that hot female
that that guys want you legit that's one
you